Dances, dragons, and a whole lot of death
—this is the life of Rhaenyra Targaryen.
Beware: heavy spoilers for "House of the Dragon"
lie ahead.
Born in 97 AC, Princess Rhaenyra is the firstborn
child of King Viserys I and Queen Aemma.
Rhaenyra's father inherits the throne in a
time of turmoil.
The fifth king of the Targaryen dynasty is
chosen to rule by the Great Council of 101
AC after the old king, Jaehaerys I, loses
both of his male heirs.
Jaeherys convenes the noble houses of Westeros
to decide who will inherit the crown as his successor.
Viserys is chosen over his cousin Rhaenys,
despite being the younger of the two.
Rhaenys, nicknamed the Queen Who Never Was,
discusses the Great Council's decision with
young Rhaenyra in the second episode of House
of the Dragon, telling the princess:
"Men would sooner put the realm to the torch
than see a woman ascend the Iron Throne."
Viserys and Aemma try multiple times to conceive
a male heir throughout their marriage, resulting
in several miscarriages, stillbirths, and,
ultimately, a brutal and bloody fate for Queen Aemma.
After a non-consensual medieval C-section
ends the queen's life, the teenage Rhaenyra
is officially named Viserys' heir.
This differs slightly from Fire And Blood
— in the book, Viserys names Rhaenyra his
heir when she is just eight years old.
King Viserys I defies tradition in naming
his daughter the heir to the Iron Throne.
However, the king does a half-hearted job
of securing Rhaenyra's position of power,
especially after he has sons by Alicent Hightower.
Rather than challenge male primogeniture,
or make a formal declaration of Targaryen
exceptionalism, Viserys seemingly just hopes
for the best, oblivious to the civil war flaring
up around him.
House of the Dragon suggests that Viserys
is motivated by a mixture of guilt for Aemma's
death and a desire to keep his hot-headed
brother Daemon away from the throne.
Does Viserys love his daughter?
Yes.
But doesn't that mean he should work harder
to secure her future as queen?
Probably.
Rhaenyra is beloved by the people of Westeros during her youth, so much so that they dub
her "The Realm's Delight" in honor of her
esteemed beauty.
As a child, she serves as a cupbearer to her
father, which gives her access to all of his
council meetings and first-hand experience
of the inner machinations of governance.
Rhaenyra's reputation plummets over the course
of her life, however.
Fire and Blood tells us the Targaryen queen
became a controversial figure in her later
years, earning some very unsavory nicknames
from the people of Westeros.
Young Rhaenyra is portrayed by Milly Alcock
in House of the Dragon, while actor Emma D'Arcy
later takes over the role as an older version
of the character.
Casting two actors to portray Rhaenyra might
be more than a practical decision on the showrunners' behalf.
By seeing two versions of Rhaenyra, viewers
get to experience the distinct phases of Rhaenyra's
life, and see how her experience in Westerosi
politics changes her over time.
In one of the earliest scenes in House of
the Dragon, Rhaenyra soars over King's Landing
on the back of her dragon.
Rhaenyra rides the dragon Syrax, nicknamed
the "Golden Beast" for her striking gold scales.
Named after a Valyrian goddess, Syrax is less
aggressive and battle-worn than Prince Daemon's
dragon, Caraxes the Blood Wyrm.
Nevertheless, Syrax is a force to be reckoned
with.
"They're a power man should never have trifled
with — one that brought Valyria its doom."
Rhaenyra takes to the sky on Syrax for the
first time at the tender age of seven.
Unlike other famous Targaryen dragons, such
as Balerion the Black Dread, Syrax only has
one rider throughout her life.
In Fire and Blood, Rhaenyra's son, Prince
Joffrey, attempts to fly Syrax — only for
the dragon to reject her rider and throw him
from her back to his death.
It's clear from the opening of House of the
Dragon that Rhaenyra and Syrax have a close bond.
But this is Westeros, where happy endings
are few and far between.
Fire and Blood hands down a terrible fate
for Syrax, who is killed by a rioting mob
that storms the Dragonpit in defiance of the
Targaryens.
In the long and bloody history of Westeros,
Rhaenyra Targaryen is the first woman to sit
on the Iron Throne.
She later has her reign disputed and discredited
by her rival Aegon II, as well as the Maesters
of the Citadel, who denounce her as a usurper.
However, Rhaenyra nevertheless sits on the
throne after her faction, known as the Blacks,
takes King's Landing from Aegon.
Rhaenyra rules for six months in King's Landing,
earning her the moniker "The Half-Year Queen."
Book lore frames her as the only woman to
have ever sat on the throne, although in Game
of Thrones, Cersei Lannister follows in Rhaenyra's
footsteps and becomes the Queen of Westeros
after the deaths of her children in the Season
6 finale.
Despite her discredited sovereignty, Rhaenyra
remains a powerful figure in the Targaryen
dynasty and an influential ancestor for Daenerys
in the books.
The Mother of Dragons is the second sovereign
queen in her family after Rhaenyra, as she
rules the city of Meereen while laying her
claim to the Iron Throne of Westeros.
The similarities between Rhaenyra and Cersei
Lannister don't end there, however.
The Targaryen queen has five children who
are key figures in the Dance of the Dragons.
Her first three children, Jacaerys, Lucerys,
and Joffrey, are born from Rhaenyra's marriage
to Ser Laenor Velaryon.
Like Cersei, however, the legitimacy of her
children is doubted, with the realm speculating
that the boys are actually the sons of Rhaenyra's
lover, Ser Harwin Strong.
"We know, father.
Everyone knows.
Just look at them."
Rhaenyra later gives birth to two more sons,
Aegon and Viserys, fathered by Prince Daemon Targaryen.
Rhaenyra is pregnant with her sixth child
when her father, Viserys, finally dies.
The news triggers a difficult labor, and tragedy
strikes twice for the Targaryen queen, as
her daughter, Visenya, does not survive the
birth.
The first time Rhaenyra Targaryen marries,
it is for duty.
The princess is wed to Ser Laenor Velaryon
in 114 AC, but makes no secret of her distaste for him.
Fire and Blood speculates that Rhaenyra was
forced to marry Laenor by Viserys, who threatened
to denounce her as his heir if she didn't
go through with the marriage.
It is heavily suggested that Laenor is gay
and in love with Ser Joffrey Lonmouth, with
whom he spends most of his time at High Tide.
Despite spending most of her time at court
away from her husband, Rhaenyra becomes friends
with Laenor's sister, Laena Velaryon, who
marries Daemon Targaryen and, in the book,
dies giving birth to their twin daughters.
When Laenor and Laena die in 120 AC, Rhaenyra
and Daemon marry in secret, against the wishes
of King Viserys.
Their relationship is creepy right from the
start: Daemon gifts his niece various trinkets
from his voyages and courts her from a young
age.
Rhaenyra's formal title as heir to King Viserys
is Princess of Dragonstone, a title passed
down to all Targaryen heirs.
Like her ancestor, Daenerys bears this title
at the beginning of Game of Thrones.
Daenerys serves as heir to her brother Viserys
as the only known Targaryen left after Robert's Rebellion.
After the deaths of Viserys and her unborn
son Rhaego, Daenerys assumes sovereignty of
House Targaryen, believing herself to be the
last of the dragonlords.
Both Daenerys' and Rhaenyra's story arcs are
driven by prophecy.
In House of the Dragon, Viserys tells his
daughter about a prophetic dream that Aegon
I once had, a dream that motivated the conqueror
to unify Westeros with fire and blood.
"Aegon saw absolute darkness riding on those
winds, and whatever dwells within will destroy
the world of the living."
The Princess of Dragonstone is heir to her
father's crown and her family's responsibility.
In order to maintain that responsibility,
Rhaenyra spends a great deal of time fending
off crown-hungry suitors from other noble
families such as House Lannister, House Frey,
and House Tyrell.
King Viserys makes Alicent Hightower his wife
in 106 AC.
The daughter of Viserys' Hand, Ser Otto Hightower,
Alicent gives birth to four children over
the next few years.
The coming of these children makes the realm
anxious.
Will Rhaenyra remain Viserys' heir?
Or will patriarchal traditions force the king
to name Prince Aegon, his eldest son, the
new heir to the throne?
To the king's credit, Viserys does not budge
— Rhaenyra is the heir, through and through.
But that doesn't stop the Targaryens from
splintering into two factions.
In Fire and Blood, Rhaenyra makes a bold statement
by dressing in the traditional Targaryen colors
to symbolize her status as the future of House
Targaryen, juxtaposing Alicent's green gown.
The two factions are thereafter dubbed the
blacks and the greens after the princess and
the queen's costumes.
Alicent and Aegon lead the greens, with Rhaenyra
and Daemon at the head of their opposition.
Aegon, who will become known as Aegon II,
rides the dragon Sunfyre, while his brother
Aemond One-Eye rides Vhagar, the oldest and
largest Targaryen dragon.
Rhaenyra and Aegon never fight directly on
their dragons.
Other characters fight — and die — on
their behalf.
The civil war decimates House Targaryen, wiping
out nearly all of the dragons and triggering
the steady decline that leads to Robert's
Rebellion.
Although she rules King's Landing for only
six months, Rhaenyra quickly becomes an unpopular queen.
The people initially cheer for her when she
takes the throne from her brother, but when
Rhaenyra hikes taxes dramatically to fund
the war, it is the people of King's Landing
who pay the price.
Starving and oppressed, the people rebel against
her.
Led by a High Sparrow-like figure named the
Shepherd, rioters take over the city, storm
the Dragonpit and kill a number of dragons.
Rhaenyra flees to Dragonstone, but Aegon and
his forces wait there in ambush.
Aegon has had a tough time by this point,
having been severely wounded multiple times
during the war.
After capturing Rhaenyra, he sentences her
to death by dragon.
Sunfyre burns and devours her, all while her
son looks on.
"It ate her while her son watched.
What's left of her is buried in the crypts,
right down there."
Most of what we know about Rhaenyra and her
family comes from Mushroom, a dwarf who served
as a court jester to the Targaryens.
Mushroom is a Tyrion Lannister archetype.
Both share a propensity for wine and bawdy
jokes, for example.
Most importantly, Mushroom and Tyrion are
underestimated by the people around them.
Like Tyrion, Mushroom uses this to his advantage
by becoming privy to important information
that the nobles don't bother to conceal from
him.
Mushroom documented an account of the Dance
of the Dragons titled The Testimony of Mushroom.
His testimony forms the backbone of Fire and
Blood, and the narrator of the history book,
Archmaester Gyldayn, does his best to discern
the truth from the lies.
Mushroom makes some pretty salacious claims
in his testimony, too.
Gyldayn compares his account of the events
to other historians, like Septon Eustace and
Grand Maester Munkun, whose tales often contradict.
Then again, in Westeros, any scandal is possible.
Mushroom doesn't appear in House of the Dragon,
though co-creator Ryan Condal has confirmed
that there will at least be some nods to the
character.
After Rhaenyra's death, it seems as if Aegon
II has won the war.
But all is not lost for the queen's cause.
The blacks continue to fight in her name,
with a new army of Northmen and knights from
the Vale approaching King's Landing.
Cregan Stark leads his soldiers to the capital,
where they discover that Aegon II has been poisoned.
The greens bend the knee to Cregan, who makes
some severe changes in the city on behalf
of Rhaenyra's son, the future King Aegon III.
Cregan's six-day rule is dubbed the "Hour
of the Wolf."
With it, the Dance of the Dragons comes to
an end.
Aegon III is crowned at the age of eleven,
though the young king remains deeply traumatized
by the death of his mother and falls into
a life-long depression.
It is during Aegon's reign that the last of
the Targaryen dragons dies, earning him the
nickname Dragonbane.
And while Rhaenyra might not win the throne
in the end, her legacy lives on — as her
ancestry extends all the way to Jon Snow and
Daenerys Targaryen, the last scions of the House of the Dragon.